Wendell from Treme here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Wendell the
dulcet tones of Wendell Pierce alright
sir uh-huh all right first of all peak
and Pennsylvania I know you listening
you said come out here I'm not coming at
you yeah we could have scored a thousand
points oh we could have we could have
hit we could have it we could have hit
Ted Ginn jr. for more points so Trey
quarrels Smith or Mark Ingram could run
for a thousand yards hey yes we don't
play football in fantasy so some of you
do I don't yes but it's not about what
could have happened it's about what did
happen and what does happen and what we
saw was the most egregious no call in
the history of the game but what what's
what's sad about it is the fact that
listen I've been at all this all the
games we've lost I was in Seattle when
we lost in 13 I saw the Beast quake run
of Marcia and I was there last year in
Minnesota I'm not gonna take away the
play from Diggs but they were football
play this was about business I think
what happens is when you see something
like this and there's no way to correct
it you know you start it you start to
glom onto the conspiracies and I just
you know there's no way that that should
happen ever I understand that Sports is
constantly and all sports there's the
close call that will have will be
arguing about forever whether whether
one thing happened was whether it was a
foul or not a follow as he's safe or was
that pitch inside a strike or not that's
objective this was sold not subjective
this was so clear and without some way
of correcting it in for the asterisk
next to this league you start to put
in a year that had been so horrible for
the NFL this assault on the First
Amendment where players can protest you
know the first year that sports book is
allowed something like this happens with
the history of you know Tim Donaghy and
MBA and that and that scandal you
started you start to wonder for me it
was like a matrix moment I can take
those other losses would be so hurt that
we lost in the final play of a playoff
game as the same trend in Minnesota last
year the miracle and all the others that
I mentioned San Francisco when Vernon is
Davis and Alex Smith ate us up in a
minute but with something like this if
you don't have it you start for me it
was a matrix moment I'll never be able
to look at the game again well let me
let me I'm sure the league will
definitely investigate anything that
you're talking about about Donaghey or
anything of that nature now but all that
said though Wendell I can I can safely
attest that when you talk about business
that I think CBS with all due respect to
the Rams and that's the business of the
NFL would be the network in the ratings
and the interest and the dollars in the
sense having Brees versus Brady would be
something I think the NFL would put
their head on the pillow and be very
happy about in Atlanta for sure so what
do you mean by the business aspect of it
just to provide a little bit of pushback
I thought about it you know what happens
is you start to wonder you start to
wonder just like at the beginning of the
season you you put in new rules and the
league comes up and says you know you
have to I want you to kind of look at
this head to head you know I want you to
make those calls you know in season I
want people to get accustomed to the
fact that this this is a new way you
have to tackle you better put your face
mass in the guy's chest and not the top
of the crowd so I want you to throw some
more flags to make sure that we get
these players accustomed to changing
their way of approaching the tackle and
not leading with the head and not
spearing and just like you
the league go to your officials and tell
them I want you to throw some more flags
if you don't have a way to rectify
something like this the fan starts to
believe that you come to your officials
and say hey last five minutes of the
game you know I kind of the we kind of
just will be a better story line you
know and so I kind of want to go this
way and hey I'm a Saints fan I thought
about this a lot the past few days go
back to week 16 against Pittsburgh
I'm sure the Pittsburgh fans feel the
same way about that call against Michael
Thomas which the guy barely touched them
but put us in a position to make sure
that we were first feet in the NFC maybe
that week the storylines with the
reality show of the NFL was Drew Brees
with a record-breaking season his number
one seed in the NFC that's what we
that's what we want the storyline to be
that week this storyline is we have a
billion done okay I'm going to go full
conspiracies you mean you haven't been
full conspiracy this whole time window I
mean you sound like Oliver Stone on
steroids I know man I am buried in hard
not so let me let me ask you this
Wendell would you what other thing
what other thing you were talking about
you were talking about ready yeah what
about that Coliseum being empty every
week and the team just being back there
in Los Angeles for three years I live in
Los Angeles I'm working at Chicago now I
live in Los Angeles that Green Bay game
nationally televised it sounded like it
was Lambeau Field nobody there you got a
billion dollar stadium there and
Inglewood there you're gonna have to
fill and then we're gonna have a Super
Bowl in in two more years we got to get
them going so we got it let me ask you
this Wendell are you swearing off the
NFL are you coming on the Rich Eisen
show and saying that this is turning you
off from Saints in the NFL fandom period
are you dropping the mic on elite man
the the league is doing everything
possible to push fans like me away
everything
listen I am a lifelong Saints fan I went
to Tulane Stadium with my dad who's 94
years old tomorrow and you know what we
did we celebrated his birthday last week
at the playoff game with the
Philadelphia Eagles
I bought a suite and celebrated his 94th
birthday it wasn't about the playoff
game for me
it was about love of family about love
of city love of my community that's
what's unique about the product that
they have they are trading on people's
love of their city of the community
every and people love their team so much
everybody thinks their tailgates are the
best oh you have no idea how we how we
cheer our stadium is the loudest it's
like that it's like that you know that
gigolo who makes every woman feel as
though she's the center of the world
right that's what the NFL does to us we
feel as though our fans and when we won
the Super Bowl yeah I called my father
that was the first person I thought of
I didn't think about the Saints I didn't
think about Archie Manning I didn't
think about all the losing seasons I
called my father and I said I Love You
Man
thank you for all those Sunday's we sat
at the top of the stadium isn't this
special we were able to create memories
around the product that they put out
there and they do a disservice when they
put out something and that you start to
believe that it's a reality show we all
know the condensed games on game paths
and Sunday Ticket there's only 30
minutes of action that they pack into
three hours of commercials so we
understand the business we know that and
we even tolerated we buy $20 beers at
the stadium we you know we go through
all of that because we love the
experience and when you just start to
assault the experience constantly over
and over and trade on the love of people
that they have with their City and their
family and the players that's the thing
that makes it tough for me I think I
don't know if I could go back to the
stadium because I know I feel like I'm
being played well Wendell you know
I gotta tell you this just it's sad to
hear that to be honest with you because
I know you know I was there in the
Superdome when the dome reopened and
what pride civic pride the the city got
through the NFL on through Brees and
Peyton and Steve Gleason and you know
the fact that you feel this way I can
only hope that some time would heal some
wounds and and you come back into that
warm fleur-de-lis Saints rich rich I was
talking all this trash right now and I
saw Steve Gleason Sunday matters it's
just great to see him
it's gonna be this I'm gonna miss all
this I'm gonna miss my people I'm gonna
miss my people and I'll be sitting there
so and I'm not gonna look at it on TV
and I'll just see what the score is or
whatever and I wonder what that player
did old manners and somebody's gonna
describe a play that I didn't see write
a catch that was made that's front row
those throws an interception that I was
married in overtime you know I'm not it
yeah so I'm gonna be I know I'm gonna be
tempted back but I hope there's a way to
rectify this they cannot this is not
about football this this is not about
football I can take losing a football
player I said in that Minnesota stadium
for an hour afterwards and I watched the
Viking fans enjoy that player I was like
man unbelievable what a play you know
dig deserves it inches by inches you
know but you know it it's one of those
things that you start to say you know
the accumulation of the mismanagement of
our Louisville team right that takes
away from the Rams if it it pits us
against it pits us against RAM fans in a
way that unnecessary you know no I know
I'm good I know and all that you know
you know and and everybody gonna go back
on bother but what about this play what
about the offenses we made and oh nine
you know I've heard it from ministers
you know my boy Josh Duhamel was like
yeah which you did the farm that's great
you know so I understand I understand
that I just wish it's about losing on a
football
play and we didn't lose on a football
play
we lost or something that I think you
have to you have to rectify you have to
rectify it and you had Michael on
yesterday Mike Sorella
my per area the former head of Everest
and he said it man he everything he said
was guerrilla I would you were saying
was brilliant all one point it's Sean is
done being the Sean Payton is going to
be in that the competition committee
next month and they're gonna fall break
it down but everyone's gonna get back to
80,000 people
it was worse in a stadium rich I saw the
television the the the televised game
after it was worse in the stadium it was
just kind of like everyone saw it
everyone knew it the two or three RAM
fans that were there I know I'm gonna
get off is you that time no no okay but
but you know to see those two guys right
there those reps just look at each other
and one call at all yeah it's just like
oh I mean it's like oh it has to be a
way to rectify I have a solution that I
have a solution just right now okay
because it's more than just losing the
game and it's more than going to the
Super Bowl it's legacy is history is
what those men and staffers worked so
long and hard for the entire lives
really become an elite athlete paid them
the bonus that they would have gotten to
go to the Super fall the incentives that
are in their contracts we blew the call
we admit it we called a minute
afterwards we blew it at least for you
here this is what you would have gotten
take some of that TV revenue that 40
million that every club gets at the
beginning of the season before you even
turn on your television from that
wonderful contract that they have with
CBS and Fox give those players what you
know you took from Noah and I absolutely
hear you and at the risk of opening up a
whole other can of worms
we have no idea if will Lutz didn't
wouldn't have hit an upright you know or
that a snap for would have gone awry I
mean we've seen that over and over again
you know and right so right we honestly
do not know and I understand there's a
movement to try and get the teams back
out on the field if you do the you know
the Trading Places turn the machines
back on that's not gonna happen either
these I'm not gonna have the okay and
and that's a fair enough point lots good
of missing you know we have no idea and
we have no idea so here's the deal
yeah hire the crew fire the rest perfect
example is I'm in Chicago right near now
yep when he hit that up right he was
fired the next day not yet but it's
coming certainly we don't know anyone on
the Today Show I think that that kind of
sealed his fate to everybody I know
you're not gonna be kicking for Chicago
no look you know what a big fan of yours
that I am and you're welcome here
anytime you're welcome to call in
anytime I hope getting this off your
chest in some way shape or form helps
like I said I hope you don't turn your
back on the sport because you're such a
great fan and a great dude so I just
wanted to chat with you today I'm glad
you reached out and thank you for my
mental health I got on the national
stage and vented Melissa man
congratulations everybody that made it
but NFL listen to what the people are
saying you're trading on their love of
city and their love of team stop the
assault on the First Amendment figure
out a way to fix this and pay my boys
their bonuses Wendell 10 you take care
of yourself okay you're the best Wendell
thanks for calling
thanks rich right back at you at Wendell
Pierce on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience